I'm Hyunse.
I'm working for the business
development team in Korea.
And today I'm here
to talk about how
to go global in a
successful manner.
And I'm going to walk through
the best practices that
is important to take
to global market.
So this is the agenda today.
I'm going to begin with
tips for global entry
and share some success
stories of actual developers
that really work
closely with us.
And at the end I will
conclude talking little bit
about the emerging trends around
the globe in the mobile world.
So today we're living
in a truly mobile world.
As mentioned in
previous presentations,
Google Play is a
truly global market.
Countries shaded
in blue represents
countries that has the largest
install base around the world.
Countries with the dollar
sign are the countries
that represent the
largest revenue
markets around the world.
Revenue-wise, Korea, Japan,
and US is the largest,
and it is constantly
growing at this moment.
Also email is growing
extremely fast
with Germany, United
Kingdom, Spain, and France
leading the growth.
So looking at the global
market, the question
will be what is needed in
order to successfully enter
the global market?
There are three
important aspects
that you need to
consider when you're
thinking about
international expansion.
You need to acquire
the right users first.
Engage with them to make them
feel that they are loved.
And retain them to make
them stay and not leave.
In order to achieve
this though, you
need to first know
your target audience
that you are targeting.
So what do I mean by
know the audience?
These three questions
are the questions
that you want to ask
during the preparation
of your global strategy.
Users use different
devices in different times,
enjoying different
content varying by region.
It is important to know
what mobile device they use,
when they use the
devices, and how
they use the devices
with what content.
In the Western
region, people tend
to use their mobile
devices sitting down.
And what I mean by sitting down,
you'll know if the next slide,
but when they are
not on the move.
In the US, for
example, mobile devices
are used mostly at home, on
your couch, after dinner.
Tablets are actually used more
in the US, in the EMEA markets,
compared to APAC
because of this reason.
Now this is APAC.
This is a typical,
everyday commuting scene
in Korea and Japan.
You may have noticed that
everyone's head is looking
down, looking into
their smart phones.
There is this funny story
about the subway in Korea.
There were a lot of
advertising agencies
that actually had ads
on ceilings of subways.
But after the launch of smart
phones in Korea, a lot of them
closed down, because
no one looked up.
So smart phones are
very heavily used
on the move in the APAC regions.
Contents are very
different also.
I want you to take a
close look at these games
before I move on
to the next slide.
There's some famous titles.
In the US, Clash
of Clans, Heyday.
Germany, we see a
game from Kabam.
These are games in
the APAC region.
Now in Korea gamers
tend to enjoy
3D, cartoonish, realistic,
online, heavy action,
multiplayer games.
And gamers are mostly
composed of core users.
In Japan you see
a lot of dragons,
you see a lot of anime,
and they're mostly
composed of hybrid genres.
Now after knowing
your audience, you
are now prepared to
enter the global stage.
I'm going to take you through
this journey, step by step.
The first thing you want
to do is acquire your users
by letting the users know that
you really care about them.
When thinking about
international expansion,
it is very important to keep the
APK size as small as you can.
The smaller the
size, more likely
the chance for the user to
download your app or your game.
Well, in Korea, you can download
one gigabyte in 30 seconds.
But if you think about
Southeast Asian countries,
it actually takes about
five to 10 minutes
to download an APK
smaller than 50 megabytes.
So keep your size
small if you're
thinking of global expansion.
The next thing that
you want to think about
is designing your icons.
Designing icons that stand out,
that is appealing to the users
is extremely important.
Because on the Play
Store, remember
that the first impression of the
users towards your app or game
is through the icons.
Some developers actually
use our Developer Console
and have different
icons by region,
trying to match with the local
tastes as much as possible.
So this is Eternity Warriors
Three by Glu Mobile.
On the left-- yes, on the left--
is the icon used in Korea,
and on the right is the icon
used in the United States.
I talk to the Country
Director of Glu Mobile
and asked him why did you use
a female character for Korea,
for your icon.
And his answer was, after
studying the Korean gaming
market, he realized that
it is important to target
the high ARPU male
gamers of Korea that
enjoy playing female
characters over male.
Upon launch, it
was able to acquire
a lot of hardcore gamers, which
brought a successful launch
in Korea for Eternity
Warriors Three.
In addition to icons,
you need to make
the titles relevant
to the local audience.
This is an example of a
game called Ace Fishing Wild
Catch developed by Come
To Us, a Korean developer.
The Korean title actually
doesn't mean Ace Fishing Wild
Catch.
Instead, if I translate it, it
translate into God of Fishing,
which is not really appealing
to the Western markets.
God of Fishing, I mean-- But
if I translate Ace Fishing Wild
Catch back into Korean,
it doesn't make any sense.
So it is really important
to make the titles right
for the local audience
that you are targeting.
Screenshots are
very important also.
It is important
to localize them,
and users, especially in APAC,
do not like unlocalized assets.
It actually makes them move
away from the apps details page,
the moment they realize
that the screenshots are not
localizing to their language.
These are screenshots of a
trends curation app called
Vingle, and they did a great
job in actually localizing
their screenshots across
different regions.
For games.
These are screenshots of
popular games in Korea, Japan,
and in the US.
For Korea and Japan,
developers tend
to use screenshots
with characters and art
that are very distinct
and very stylized.
In the Western market,
characters and visuals
are more realistic compared
to that of Korea and Japan.
Now if you take all
these steps and are
ready for the global
launch, the Google Play Team
is here for you to expose your
global content through our Play
Stores across regions.
What you see now are the
Play Stores in Japan, Korea,
and in the United States.
We are here to
help you to acquire
real users all around the world.
Now once you successfully
acquired your users,
it is time to engage with them.
You need to know your
users that you've
acquired in order to do so.
In Korea and Japan,
pre-registration
is a very popular way to
engage users before launch.
So what you do is, if a user
registers before launch,
they will receive a
small, in-app gift,
once the game or
app is launched.
Now according to the
developers in Asia, this tool
is the most powerful tool to
get the user into action, even
before launch.
When designing a game
or an app, you also
need to think about
the different UIs
that different regions like.
In Japan, for example,
what you see on the left,
there is a lot of information
crammed into one screen.
However, contents that
are popular in the West,
has a much more simpler UI, and
is much more straightforward.
Having the correct UI design for
the target market will be also
a very important aspect in
keeping the users from leaving,
once they install
your game or an app.
When you localize, you
need to be very careful,
and be very accurate.
If you take a look at
the Korean at the top,
it looks pretty much the same.
Circles, squares.
Right?
But there is a big
error in the line break.
So if I write this
out in English,
hi my name is Mic hael.
So the line break is right
in the middle of Michael,
which can be very disturbing
to the Korean users.
And especially in APAC users are
very sensitive about language.
So it is very important
to localize accurately,
to make the users feel
that they're being loved.
And [? Broheme ?]
mentioned this,
pricing is also very important.
The $0.99 is for the
dollar, the Euro.
But in Korea and Japan,
it all ends with a zero.
Regarding monetization
of games, it
is also very different
across regions.
In the Western markets,
users tend to use more money.
On in-app purchases, in
speeding up progress,
such as building buildings
and upgrading them.
This is a little
different in APAC, though.
Gamers in APAC spend the most
money in the Gotcha System.
Does anyone not know
what a Gotcha System is?
OK.
It is a very popular in-app
tactic that the APAC users use.
Basically, it's
like a lucky draw.
Through this lucky draw,
you upgrade your characters,
you get equipment, you get
five star rated shields,
through this lucky draw.
And this is the most
popular in-app tactic,
and the most popular in-app
that the APAC users actually
use money on.
So now that you have
the users engaged,
your next step is to
think about retention.
You have your users in action,
and you don't want your users
to stop their action and leave.
Globally successful developers
provide customer service
in languages that they support
within their game or app.
This is very important
since it connects
to your rating on the Play
Store which [? Broheme ?] just
showed you.
And listening to user feedback
of the global audience
actually teaches developers
a lot of new information.
Making them able
to provide the best
service for the
regional audience.
Notifications are powerful
tools in user retention.
It is important to design
events and notify users
so that they are constantly
being entertained.
Korean developers for example,
have events and updates
once to twice every week,
in order to keep the users
entertained.
But when you design your events,
you need to be very careful.
You need to make the events
relevant to the audience
that you're targeting.
Valentine's Day, for example,
as you look in the screen,
it's a screenshot from
Badland, developed by Frogmind,
was used as a theme of their
map during Valentine's Day.
But this is not a big day
in APAC, compared to the US.
So seasonal events tend to work
well in the Western regions,
but in the APAC regions,
it's a different story.
In Japan, for example,
collaboration with strong IPs
is the most popular method of
events within games and apps.
Clash of Clans,
when it got popular,
it had a collaboration
with Puzzle and Dragons.
And Puzzle and
Dragons is actually
collaborating with
Dragon Ball, which
is the biggest anime
franchise in Japan.
In Korea, local celebrities
are actually used on events.
There's this game
called Legion of Heroes
by-- it's a very core
MORPG game, developed
by Nexon Company.
They used actual
popular celebrities
and made in-game
characters of them.
Again, targeting the
high ARPU male gamers
that enjoy using female
characters for game play.
So now I'm going to talk about
a little about success cases
from Korea, that
actually was successful
in the global market.
The developers that
I'm about to show you
are developers that
we have been working
very closely in the Korea team.
So this app is called Vingle.
I showed you this app
for the localization
part in screenshots.
What is great about
this app is that allowed
its global success was following
the Android design guidelines.
They use Action Bar
Navigation Drawer, and tabs,
making it easy for the
global audience that
use Android to use this app.
Currently Vingle is rated
4.8 from the global users.
And the users are constantly
growing at this moment.
The second app I
want to talk about
is an app called Polaris Office.
This is an app that allows
users to edit office documents
on your tablet or on
your mobile phone.
Not only they follow
the design guidelines,
but they also use a
subscription model
that [? Broheme ?] talked about.
And they're actually constantly
generating revenue every month
for the premium
version for service.
They currently have two
million users, worldwide,
and 90% of the
users are overseas.
For games, this is a game
called Summoners War, which
was developed by a Korean
developer, Come to Us.
This game has around 3.7
current users at this moment,
and it's mostly composed
of users outside of Korea.
They're holding regional events,
that I mentioned in my session.
In-game for local users
in different areas.
They're providing customer
support in six languages.
And they're engaging with users
through local communities.
More than 60% of the
revenue currently
is generated by this game
is happening overseas.
So I walk through the journey
of how to go to global.
And I showed you
some case studies
of successful global entry.
Before I wrap up, I would like
to talk about some emerging
trends in the mobile world.
Mobile devices are
not phones anymore.
They are the ultimate tool
for high quality entertainment
content.
The higher the
quality, the better
chance of you having
real users that
matter all around the world.
Korea developers these days,
are using the mobile devices
to provide stunning
games of high quality.
On the left side you see
a high quality MORPG game,
and on the right a baseball
game, that is close to real
and is using actual
baseball players in Korea.
Users today are always
connected everywhere.
Engagement with the users as
a developer is also important,
but engagement among
users is becoming
a key trend in the mobile world.
For games, players engage by
playing together with friends.
And for apps, users see
each other's activities,
what they're doing on their app.
Contents that involve
users within the content,
are growing fast all
around the world.
Connecting from
the previous slide,
it is important to keep
the users engaged even more
outside of the game or
app through empowering
your communities.
And if you have a
chance, don't hesitate
to go beyond the digital world.
Create a franchise
just like what
Gung Ho did for Puzzle
and Dragons, which
is the picture at the top.
And like what Rovio
did with Angry Birds.
Angry Birds is actually very
popular the licensing business
in Korea, and it's trying
to expand into Japan
also, at this moment.
So whenever you're ready, or
have questions regarding APAC.
Don't hesitate to
reach out to our teams.
We have a strong team in APAC.
Japan, led by Yoshi,
Korea, led by my boss, KH.
And traditional Chinese
markets led by Kevin in Taiwan.
Here today we have
teams from Mountain View
and from EMEA that's helping you
expand into those territories.
But whenever you're ready
to enter the APAC market,
don't hesitate to
email us and we will
be willing to help
you grow your business
in the international world.
That's all I have for today.
Thank you for listening.